This video is going to demonstrate how we do our podcast hosting over here at
Ryker Medical. There is a written set of notes that goes along with it that is
posted on our blog over on the web page. We'll also add a link in the notes of
this video. As a quick summary, we used to use a third-party service to do the
podcast, but the issue is that is that if that service ever goes away or if there's
an issue with our account, we'd have to start all over. Creating our own RSS feed
allows us to manage the thing independently. If a given host ever goes
away, we simply port the thing over to another host without much headache. We
held off on doing this for a while because we didn't know how to do it and
didn't know how to code or host the thing. We've got it all worked out now and
here we are sharing it with you and the world. So these are the steps we'll work
through. No need to discuss them now, let's just move on to number one. Hosting
our files on archive.org. Archive.org and the Internet Archive is a cool project
that seeks to save things on the Internet for future generations. Another
cool thing you can do on archive.org is upload and save files to their program,
which is perfect for our podcast situation because we need to get our
podcast files from our devices up onto the Internet so others can access them.
The video is showing the super simple process of uploading an audio file, a
podcast episode, along with a photo onto the platform. Of course you'll need to
become a user and make a free account, but we've omitted showing all the
details simply to save space and time. And then as you can see it allows us to
enter metadata, although we don't necessarily have to, and now we have our
files hosted on a page at archive.org, which is rad. There are specific ways in
which archive.org hosts these files that is fundamentally different from say
OneDrive or Google Drive and allows us to use this process for podcast hosting.
We've discussed that a bit in the blog post that goes with this so take a look
there if you're interested. And all of the clips of us doing things are screen
captures on an iPad, but you can also do this in a browser just as easy. Sweet.
So files on the Internet. Next step is to build and host an XML file on GitHub.
First sub step here is to set up the GitHub page. Now GitHub is a platform for
software developers and programmers to host, share, collaborate on code. We have
found a way to use it for our podcast hosting needs, but that's not necessarily
what the thing was intended for. That said, it works pretty well. So go make an
account, log in to this main page. We have to set the system up from a web browser,
but once it's all good to go, we can edit the thing and publish episodes from the
GitHub app on any device. Let's start by making a new repository called landing.
We'll then make the following pages. Read me, feed and landing. The read me will
probably be created or prompted automatically by GitHub when you create the landing repository.
You can type whatever you want here and that description will show on the repository page.
Then you create the feed dot XML and index dot HTML files by clicking add file and create
new file as shown. We'll talk more about the feed dot XML file in just a moment.
That's the code that makes this thing work. And the index file we think allows the page
to get found on the Internet. But to be honest, we're not exactly sure how that works.
Just that it's a necessary ingredient to this whole thing without it, the system won't work.
And then the next step is to enable GitHub pages as outlined in these steps, which were
provided by chat GPT because we couldn't figure out how to make it all go once we got this far.
And then we'll have a URL for our GitHub page. All right. Next step is to create the XML file,
which as I already mentioned is the code portion of the RSS feed. Go back to the repository,
click on the feed dot XML file, then hit the edit tab up in the top right. From here on out,
you can always edit the feed dot XML file from either the browser or from the GitHub
app or whatever device you're on. This specific example shows how it looks on an iPad.
Now the text or body of the feed dot XML file contains all the information about the podcast.
Up top is general information. Then each episode will have its own entry. And then the bottom,
we just have to remember to close all the open tabs for everything. There are general rules for
what needs to be in an RSS feed for it to work across platforms. And then there are specific
rules for different hosts. We recommend following Apple podcast rules, as they've pretty much
monopolized the space. And most other hosts will work just fine if you follow the more stringent
requirements of Apple. And then this is what the feed dot XML code or file looks like. If you open
your RSS feed URL in a browser, to get you started on this part, simply copy the code shown here from
our write up or blog post, we included a text version of our feed. And also like a made up
example, you can just copy that and then edit to add your specific content. One thing to point out
here is the URL in the screenshot, your URL for your XML file will be similar, except that will
have your username on GitHub in place of record medical, you'll need this URL in the next step,
which then takes us to validating our RSS feed. This step basically allows us to see if the XML
file works as it's supposed to. You basically use an RSS validator tool, drop in your feeds URL,
and it gives you a report on any issues. There are many of these, these are two that we use. And
then here's how it looks. Now, if you run into an issue, and you can't sort it out with the feed
validator tool, for example, if it gives you something to change, and you're not quite sure
what it says, you can use chat GBT or any other AI tool, share your feed with them and they can
help troubleshoot, which is exactly what we did with our feed when we first swapped to the system.
So that's what the video is showing. And then of course, once you make a change, just be sure to
go validate it again, until it's all good to go. Last step, we'll show you how to host the RSS feed
on both Spotify, which is what we use at right grammatical and Apple, which is also totally just
fine to use. And we've used it for other things in the past. In either case, you make an account,
and then you have to manually add the URL you want instead of the one that they assign to you. The
steps here are pretty self explanatory. As you can see in the videos, it's mostly a matter of just
knowing where to find the space to insert your RSS feed. And that's it. Now you can fulfill all
your podcasting dreams and carry the fruits of your labor from platform to platform without
ever having to worry about needing to rebuild it all over again.